la mañana de este miércoles 23 de
diciembre arribo al aeropuerto
internacional de la ciudad de méxico
procedente de bélgica y con una escala
en cincinnati el primer embarque de la
vacuna de facer que será aplicada a
partir de este jueves 24 a personal
médico que está en la primera línea de
batalla contra el hobbit 19 para la
recepción de estos paquetes que llegaron
en un avión de una empresa de mensajería
asistieron los secretarios de relaciones
exteriores hacienda defensa marina y
salud entre otros funcionarios que
dijeron que este día es histórico pues
méxico está entre los 10 primeros países
en tener acceso al fármaco el presidente
lópez obrador ha dicho que la vacunación
será universal y gratuita y que no será
de carácter obligatorio comenzará a
aplicarse el antígeno en la ciudad de
mexico y en coahuila y se trata del
arribo de las primeras dosis que aunque
no se dijo la cantidad exacta de las que
llegaron si se mencionó que a finales de
enero se espera la recepción de un
millón 400 mil dosis de la vacuna de
facer mientras se autorizan los otros
laboratorios